Joe Biden promised to deliver 100 million vaccine
doses into the arms of Americans in 100 days,
and we are, I am thrilled to say, on
track to dramatically surpass that.
And at the same time, we are seeing
coronavirus cases continue to decline
very quickly, faster than than many people
expected. So let's run through the numbers then. I
have other covid updates. We did this each of the
last few weeks. I didn't think that many people
would would actually like this. But it turns out
a lot of people aren't following the day to day
of what's going on with the virus, understandably.
And a ton of people wrote in saying actually the
summaries are useful in terms of where we are.
So let's jump right in with one disclaimer.
I'm going to give a lot of optimistic news in this
segment. It should not be used to encourage us
to stop being careful. The optimistic news should
tell us, let's keep being careful, not go crazy.
And if we do that, then there is hopefully a light
at the end of the tunnel. And yes, I will address
the variance, of course. All right. So let's start
with cases. Coronavirus cases on average peaked
on January 11th at about two hundred and fifty
five thousand cases per day, an insane number.
The good news is that since that peak cases have
declined a whopping 64 percent, where we are
now averaging ninety two thousand cases per day.
Now, this is all perspective. At one point a year
ago when Dr. Fauci said not a year ago, 10, eight
months ago, seven months ago, when Dr. Fauci said,
if we aren't careful, we could get up to 100000
cases per day in the fall. And a whole bunch of
people said that's impossible. And of course,
Dr. Fauci was right. We weren't careful and we
actually got not to 100000 cases a day, not to
200000 cases a day. We actually had hundred,
300000 cases a day. We had 300000 cases on
one day in the fall. We are now back down
to ninety two thousand cases per day.
But what matters is the rate of decline
down 64 percent in just 35 days. You love to see
it. Let's keep it going now. In the meantime,
deaths which lag cases by three to four weeks,
are finally starting to come down, peaking at an
average of about 3500 deaths a day in the United
States, more 20 percent more than a 9/11 a day
now down 25 percent to a daily average of about
2600 deaths per day. Still an unconscionable,
horrifying number, but we are seeing the
improvement and the improvement in deaths should
track the decline in cases as well, with about
a three to four week lag. Now to vaccination.
Joe Biden promised a million doses a day.
The U.S. is now exceeding that by a full
two thirds with one and two thirds million
vaccine doses per day going into people's arms
with again, new record days this weekend, two
point two million doses administered on Saturday,
two point two million doses administered
on Sunday. These are fantastic numbers,
but they are not enough because at the
current rates, we wouldn't hit 50 percent
immunity until June 28th. We wouldn't
reach 70 percent immunity, a key number
until September 5th. So as I've said before, I
didn't come up with this. Medical experts did.
The ideal would be to get to three point five
million doses per day that would dramatically
accelerate our progress. It's not impossible
that we would get there with a third vaccine
and hopefully with a fourth vaccine. Now, let's
talk about vaccines and variants. Once again,
we continue to learn more and more about this. We
have two vaccines currently in use in the United
States, the Moderna vaccine and the Fizer vaccine.
These are both Tudor's vaccines with Moderna.
You have twenty eight days between
doses. With Pfizer, you have 21 days
between doses. OK, we are close to approval for
a third vaccine, the Johnson and Johnson vaccine.
That is a one dose vaccine that will dramatically
simplify logistics and could get us could get us
to 2.5, three million vaccines a day regularly for
vaccine has the possibility of getting us to three
and a half million vaccines a day. Meanwhile, what
we know about the effectiveness of these vaccines
is stunning. It's not a miracle, it's science.
So I don't want to use the word miracle, but
the numbers appear almost miraculous. Israel has
done an incredible job with vaccination. They're
already vaccinating younger people. And the deal
they made with Pfizer is that they will open up
their data so Pfizer can get more information
about how the vaccine works. In reality,
one study. The vaccinated Israeli population found
that in the real world, the vaccine has 94 percent
efficacy at preventing symptomatic disease and a
92 percent drop in severe disease. Listen to these
numbers. A study of five hundred and twenty
five thousand vaccinated Israelis found only
500 of them got the virus. That's zero point one
percent, five hundred twenty five thousand people.
Five hundred get the virus with the vaccine. And
that was including some of them got it between
doses. They weren't yet at full immunity.
Of the 500 people that got the virus,
four of the five hundred had what you would call
a serious case, four, and none of them died.
These are incredible, incredible numbers, the
vaccine appears to be as good in real life as
it was in the Phase three trials. Now, it's not
all great news. We are in a fight against these
variants that are spreading. The good news in
that fight is that the Moderna and Fizer vaccines
appear really effective against the UK variant
and the Brazilian variant, and they appear less,
but still quite effective. Against the South South
Africa variant, it's just a matter of speed, the
faster we vaccinate, the more we prevent mutation,
the more we prevent the spread of the variants,
which are slightly stronger against the vaccine.
If you imagine the variants in a fight against
the vaccines and the more we can control the.
So if we can keep this going, we are going to
have a very different situation statistically
in the United States by April 1st. And again,
a different situation by May 1st. If we can get
beyond one in two thirds million vaccines a day,
if we can get to two point five steady or three,
we are looking at moving up the date at which
70 percent of the country will be vaccinated from
early September into August, possibly even into
July or according to some models, even late June,
if we can really quickly ramp up vaccination. So
let's keep tracking numbers. The milestone I'm
next looking for is when we get under 50000 cases
per day, that might only be weeks away. If we can
keep going, it could be longer. We will soon see.
And fortunately, vaccine hesitancy. I won't dove
into that a lot now because we did that last week.
Vaccine hesitancy also continues to go
down. All good things. We are hoping also
for approval on the vaccination of kids, you
know, 10, 12, 14 years old by early summer,
optimistically. And that will also be a big
factor. So a lot of good things happening.
Not the time to go crazy, not the time to go
crazy. Light at the end of the tunnel. We see it